♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE'VE BEEN TELLING
YOU MONTHS NOW FOR THE GROWING
POWER OF THE BIG TECH COMPANIES
WHOSE BRAND SURVEILLANCE
CAPITALISM HAS COME TO SHAPE OUR
POLITICS AND CULTURE.
IN WAYS MANY PEOPLE DON'T
RECEIVE.
LET ME GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC
ILLUSTRATION OF THE CONTROL OF
THESE COMPANIES SEEK OVER OUR
DAILY LIVES.
WE RECENTLY REVIEWED SEVERAL
PATENTS FILED BY GOOGLE.
THIS MUCH POWER TO UNELECTED
IN THE FIRST FILED IN
DECEMBER 2016, GOOGLE ENVISIONS
AN ILLUSTRATION THAT GOOGLE
SUBMITTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, THE PATENT OFFICE,
AND CAMERA IN YOUR BEDROOM SEES
WATCHING THE MOVIE.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S CREEPY,
PREPARE YOURSELF.
IT GETS A LOT CREEPIER.
IN ANOTHER PATENT APPLICATION IN
2016, GOOGLE IMAGINES HOW IT CAN
TAKE CONTROL OF YOUR PARENTING,
THE RELATIONSHIP TO YOUR
DETECT CHILDREN IN YOUR LIQUOR
CABINET OR IN THEIR PARENTS
BEDROOM.
A HYPOTHETICAL CHILD CALLED
BENJAMIN, GOOGLE'S CAMERAS WOULD
BE WATCHING BENJAMIN AT ALL
TIMES.
USING ELECTRONICS, USING
INFORMATION TO SELL THINGS AT
SOME POINT BECAUSE OF THE WHOLE
POINT, GOOGLE.
THE SAME PATENT ALSO DISCUSSES
HOW THE SMART HOME COULD COACH
FAMILIES ON AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT.
IF A FAMILY DOES NOT SPEND
ENOUGH TIME TOGETHER, EATING
TOGETHER, IN GOOGLE'S
ESTIMATION, GOOGLE MIGHT SCHOOL
THEM AND SUGGEST THEY SET A GOAL
IN EATING MORE OFTEN TOGETHER.
THAT IS GOOGLE'S DESCRIPTION.
NOT OURS.
WE ARE ASSUMING IT WAS A PERSON,
NOT A ROBOT, REPLIED THIS WAY.
"WE FILED PATENT APPLICATIONS ON
A VARIETY OF IDEAS OUR EMPLOYEES
COME UP WITH.
SOME OF THE MATURE INTO A
PRODUCT OR.
SOME DON'T."
IN OTHER WORDS, DON'T WORRY.
WE AREN'T SPYING ON YOU, NEXT TO
IT WE JUST HAVE A PATENT ON IT.
OF COURSE, TECH IS ALSO
DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT'S DEEPLY
ADDICTIVE.
MORE THAN ANYTHING, IT'S DEEPLY
A GROUP OF EARLY GOOGLE,
FACEBOOK EMPLOYEES ARE TEAMING
UP TO CHECK THE COMPANIES THEY
HELPED CREATE.
GROUP, THE CENTER FOR HUMANE
TECHNOLOGY.
JIM STIER IS THE FOUNDER OF
COMMON SENSE MEDIA WHICH
ADVOCATES FOR CHILDREN.
THEY JOIN US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU, BOTH, FOR COMING
TONIGHT.
HE DESCRIBED THESE PRODUCTS AS
ADDICTIVE.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN BY THAT?
>> MOST PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE,
THEY SEE ADDICTION AND THEY
THINK IT HAPPENS BY ACCIDENT.
WE ARE ADDICTED TO A LOT OF
THINGS.
WE WERE WORRIED ABOUT OUR KIDS
IN THE 1970s, WE WERE ADDICTED
TO GOSSIPING ON THE TELEPHONE.
WHAT THIS MISSES, THERE ARE 100
ENGINEERS WHOSE ENTIRE JOB, NOT
BECAUSE THEY ARE EVIL, THEY HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET BACK TO
THE PRODUCTS.
SNAPSHOTS WANT TO PUT THE NUMBER
OF DAYS IN A ROW, SOMETHING
CALLED A STREAK, NEXT TO EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN YOUR KIDS
CONTACTS.
THEY SAY, IF YOU GOT 30 FRIENDS,
HERE IS THE NUMBER DAYS IN A ROW
YOU'VE SENT A MESSAGE TO EACH
FRIEND.
IT KEEPS EACH OF THEM HOOKED,
BECAUSE THE BUSINESS MODEL MUST
SO LONG AS IT'S ADVERTISING, HOW
DO I HOLD ON TO YOUR ATTENTION.
THE ENTIRE TALK
STOCK PRICE IS LINKED
ONE-TO-ONE WITH HOW MUCH
ATTENTION I GET.
>> Tucker: WE KNOW, JIM,
SCREEN TIME HAS HUGE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> HUGE BECAUSE ONCE IT IS.
>> Tucker: IT HURTS CHILDREN.
>> IT CAN.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE
DISTURBING METRICS, SOME OF THEM
ARE LINKED TO TECH USE.
WHY HAS THERE BEEN NO PUBLIC
RECOGNITION?
>> I RUN COMMON SENSE MEDIA.
IT HAS TAKEN TIME.
WE AREN'T ANTI-TECH.
WE AREN'T ANTI-TECH AT ALL.
COMMON SENSE HELPS YOU FIND THE
GOOD STUFF.
BUT THERE IS CLEARLY BEEN NO
I THINK WHAT'S HAPPENING, YOU
ARE A DAD JUST LIKE I AM.
I'M NOT SURE I WANT THIS IN MY
LIFE ALL THE TIME.
I DON'T WANT THIS COMING YEAR.
HE JUST TOLD YOU ADDICTION IS,
BUT 60% OF KIDS IN THE
UNITED STATES BELIEVE THEY ARE
ADDICTED TO THEIR CELL PHONES.
>> Tucker: SO YOU WORKED IN
HERE.
ARE THEY AWARE -- THEY MUST BE
AWARE.
THE DESIGN MUST BE ADDICTIVE.
DO THEY HAVE MORAL QUALMS ABOUT
THIS?
>> IN 2013, I CREATED A
PRESENTATION, THE FIRST GOOGLE
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT WE DO, WE
BUMP OUR ELBOWS, A BILLION
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION BECAUSE THAT
WAY, A BILLION PEOPLE'S
ATTENTION BECAUSE THAT WAY.
HOW DO YOU ETHICALLY STEER
2 BILLION PEOPLE, ACTUALLY,
THEIR THOUGHTS, WHEN THEY LOOK
AT A SMARTPHONE OR IF YOU'D?
FROM THE MOMENT WE WAKE UP IN
THE MORNING TO 150 TIMES WE
CHECK PER DAY, IT'S NEVER BEEN
EASIER IF IT'S BEEN A KID.
YOU SEE PHOTO AFTER PHOTO WITH
YOUR FRIENDS NOT HAVING FUN WITH
YOU.
IS THAT HOW WE WANT TO ETHICALLY
CARE FOR ALL THESE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF KIDS?
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK, JIM,
THERE'S ENOUGH PEOPLE AT THESE
COMPANIES WHO CAN SEE CLEARLY
>> THIS IS THE CIGARETTE CASE
ALL OVER AGAIN.
WE WERE JUST WITH A GROUP OF
ENGINEERING COLLEAGUES SAYING
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
THE KEY IS THE LEADERSHIP AT THE
TOP.
I TELL YOU THIS IS A MAJOR
CHALLENGE NOW TO THE PEOPLE AT
THE VERY TOP OF THE KEY TECH
COMPANIES AT THE UNITED STATES.
WHEN VALUES DO YOU HAVE?
IS ABOUT HOW MUCH VALUE YOU
MAKE, HOW MUCH ATTENTION, THE
SELLING ADS?
OR IS IT FOR VALUE?
BY THE WAY, THIS IS NOT A
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: IT'S RECKONING
SOCIETY.